[Music]
the worldwide total of reported
coronavirus cases
has topped 90 million britain has opened
several mass vaccination centers
trying to protect its most vulnerable
people britain's lost 30
000 people to covet in just the last 30
days
and officials say the worst is still to
come charlie dagetta is at one of those
vaccination sites
the famous epsom race course outside
london charlie good morning
good morning to you what makes this
different to the us system
well one of it is organization these
people were all sent letters inviting
them to come for a vaccine
the other is the use of the oxford
vaccine itself it's easier to store and
distribute
and that is really ramped up the
vaccination program here
at the sprawling epsom racecourse a
different race is underway
to reach as many vulnerable people as
possible before the runaway strain of
the virus does
like 88 year old cliff taylor a jockey
who used to race on this very course
the sooner we all get our vaccination
the sooner we can get rid of this
horrible disease
that is why that you know anybody that
turns it down
they want to have a second think about
it
few second thoughts here a region
southwest of london that has seen
death surge so badly a temporary
mortuary has had to handle the overflow
of bodies
they came forward for vaccinations by
the thousands without hesitation
my mother's been desperate to have it
yeah so she was very pleased to get the
letter
and and couldn't wait seven super
vaccination centers opened up across the
country
in addition to 200 hospital sites and
hundreds of doctors offices
the ambitious goal to administer the
first vaccine shot to around 15 million
of the most vulnerable people by the
middle of next month
and so the race is on and the stakes
could hardly be higher
this mass vaccination rollout comes as
the chief medical officer warns
that the country is headed into the most
dangerous few weeks
since the pandemic began
[Music]
it's brutal and getting worse more than
81
000 people have died despite a
nationwide lockdown the new strain of
the virus is surging
it's now estimated that one in 50 people
across the country
are carrying the virus in london that
number could be as high as 1
in 20. it's a race against time
the demand in intensive care units
the pressure on on ventilated beds uh
even the shortage of oxygen
in some places
now at the moment vaccination centers
like these are open from 8 am until 8 pm
but already the government is under
pressure to adopt
the israeli model and that would be
offering vaccinations
24 hours a day anthony could come to
that charlie daggett at ups and downs in
southern england thank you charlie